hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Pacific now this is a
pixelated style horror game in the genre
of I'm scared and various games like
that I haven't played one of these games
in a long time
moreover being that there haven't been
one of these games in a long time but
they often lead into dark and terrifying
situations the likes of which you've
never seen before hello hi okay why
hello like that was that excuse you
hi okay you gonna do something to me cuz
I don't know I want it
alright okay
oh [ __ ] high okay it sounds gonna be
huh whoa oh okay
hi how long have you been there have I
just been stupid oh it would do you lock
so doesn't matter
okay hey come on now don't do this to me
[Music]
these country maintained in this
troubled world
well don't all of that sounds like peace
to me but okay
oh okay love early that is oh hello
survival under atomic attack great I'd
love that but am I gonna be haunted by
demons in exchange what happens if I
close the door okay all right back where
I thought I was what happens if I close
this door oh is that how I changed it oh
oh oh
kooky Pookie okay okay something
happened during the adieu oh why
alrighty then
well weird okay hello oh good convenient
[Music]
okay Britain's first atomic weapon
that's good for Britain but what does
that mean for me
oh you're gone now okay Frick ah yes
excellent I shall close the door and
then I shall oh it didn't change this
room at all
I did okay never okay all right I know
what I'm being dict with and I expressly
don't like being dick wood okay well I
push the chair around I think I worked
out my aggression things fine
ah good my dad's do i ducting cover
under is there someone - oh my god
there's people here there's people on
the beds I didn't know that ah didn't
know that at all
[Music]
is a trail of devastation such as the
world has never known here and there an
isolated structure reminds them okay oh
look another one is it gonna be live put
my defenses on you [ __ ] you doing you
piece of [ __ ] you think you scare me no
oh it's a door now ah good I'll just
hide in this closet use me you still
there
never mind you're locked good you just
wanted some privacy under your covers
okay never bow right even oh hello well
this is very helpful Swonk so I'm here
Oh stairs I like a stair so goody I
don't like the sound that
[Music]
okay I can't I don't know what you want
from me go every second I turn a corner
I get disappointed oh hi okay I don't
know what all right then why it's you
sure okay back down the stairs we go
then is it wet down here for me did that
turn on a light rock good did it
unlocked it I think all right here we go
[Music]
ladies thank you
they've got that in the pocket now all
good
you gonna rise
[Music]
ah this is looping forever its looping
forever so it's not
as pointed out that it would be unfair
to random while still alone now the
three breakout had no a form of erotica
easier to reach agreement on this
controversial problem now that America
Russia
[Music]
[Applause]
sure great back I golden okay
this is oh hi thank you for playing
vinaigrette on our guitars what a dance
LAN event damn Taiwan know what you just
couldn't leave it at flat did you make
this in 24 hours that was incredible
is that actually good god that was
amazing
that's how it is with these into you
like these pixelated or games you never
know what you're gonna get but with what
it works it's amazing I guess that's the
end
[Music]
so I'm just gonna say goodbye and
there's a roomful of bodies so thank you
everybody so much for watching everyone
check out dan on twitter and dan keep
this up this was really something
special it ended too soon you made this
in 29 hours think of what you could do
with a couple weeks Oh anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought it's down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you
[Music]